Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P..
Here is a caller who says WOAK and cancelations
are merely constructs that don't exist.
What?
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 4: Yes, sir.
I'm calling simply because the terms work
and counsel don't exist, they are constructs
that have been created by social media.
It would be useful if you stopped promoting
them.
Speaker 1: Well, first of all, I don't really
promote them.
We do talk about them on the show.
In a sense.
Isn't everything a construct?
I mean, like, I guess a rock isn't a construct.
It's a physical rock.
But aren't most political discussions made
up of constructs and things that as societies
we've agreed?
I don't know, and I'm having trouble following
it.
Let's listen to a little more.
Speaker 4: These are words that people think
they know what they're talking about.
Rest assured, they do not work.
What does that mean, that you suddenly become
aware of the fact that there is injustice
in America canceled?
Well, you know, we have other terms and phrases
for disavowing those who failed to meet our
criteria.
But, you know, imagining that this is in some
way associated with a culture is just bizarre.
So I'm hoping we can get you to stop using
these words as they have been presented.
Speaker 1: So I often get voicemails asking
me not to do something that I've not done
or responding to things I haven't covered.
I don't use the term WOAK in an unironic way.
The only times I've used the term WOAK are
to point-to-point fun at its absurd usage
by others.
So I mean, listen, in a sense, all of these
concepts are constructs.
We always have synonyms we can use, but I
don't really know what exactly the point is
of the call, particularly since when I talk
about the left cans, I'm sorry.
When I talk about a the right has canceled
someone while claiming to be against cancelations,
I am sort of using the term tongue in cheek.
When I talk about WOAK ism, it's often a reaction
to the right's kind of weird use of it.
I don't use the term WOAK in a real way, so
maybe the caller and I are on the same page,
but at the same time, maybe we're not.
I don't really know.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Joe Biden has canceled.
Speaking of which, Donald Trump's planned
National Garden of American Heroes and it's
triggering people.
And we're going to talk about the origins
of it and much more.
This is a funny story.
A bunch of people sent me, Harry Styles, who's
a British musician, got an award recently
and he seemed to no longer have a British
accent.
And I have a bunch of funny related stories
about this.
And I think it'll be an entertaining story
at minimum.
And then we do still have, at least in theory,
the rescheduled Olympics coming later this
year to Japan.
80 percent of the Japanese oppose the Olympics
being done in Japan this summer.
We're going to talk about why, what's going
on, the preparations that are being made,
could it be done safely, et cetera, et cetera,
and much more, including some of the upcoming
plans for the show over the next few weeks.
Don't miss today's bonus show.
That's just a suggestion.
It's not an authoritarian demand.
It's just I think you would enjoy the bonus
show.
You can get instant access to it by signing
up at join Pakman Dotcom.
That also comes with many other great benefits,
including the commercial free version of the
daily audio and video show.
The members only newsletter, invitations to
occasional members, only town halls and other
events, and the pleasure of knowing you're
supporting alternatives to homogenous corporate
media.
Sign up at Join Patman Dotcom and I will see
you in here.
Moments on today's show.